cuáles son las implicaciones de esta
visita respecto de lo que es la
solicitud de ucrania para ingresar a la
unión europea con gusto saludar de
santiago y es dando respuesta a la
continuada pregunta pues esto se da pero
por un lado tenemos que ver que se da a
la luz de pocas horas del anuncio
comparte a la comisión europea para
poder darle formalmente ya el estatus de
candidato para poder pasar toda una
serie de procedimientos para ingresar al
unión europea también se da a escasos
días previos a la cumbre del g7 y a la
cumbre de la otan ambas cumbres que se
realizarán en próximos a personas de 10
días una pues está realizándose en
alemán y la otra en madrid y esto pues a
la luz que fortalece mucho el hacer un
frente común para poder estar enviando
estas señales claras a moscú con
respecto a esta larga guerra que cada
vez vemos más lejano el proceso de paz
santiago y porque cree que se han
demorado todos estos meses estos líderes
europeos en ir a ucrania las críticas se
asociaron hoy desde parís por la visita
de macrón que se da a días de la segunda
vuelta de las legislativas
así es estamos viendo que varios líderes
santiago están aprovechando este momento
para poder abonar capital político a sus
campañas o bien a poder subir sus
niveles de aprobación como ha sido en el
caso el mandatario estadounidense en el
caso de francia sabemos muy claramente
que manuel marco ha utilizado la guerra
como un elemento para finalmente
posicionarse en este segundo mandato y
ahora ante las legislativas que cada vez
se ve más claro que va a ser el partido
y la coalición de malentxo que logrará
más escaños en la asamblea nacional por
el lado alemán pues sabemos que también
hay todo un contexto histórico que había
prolongado el que finalmente el
canciller alemán pudieran realizar esta
visita dado esta historia compartida en
cuestiones del holocausto y todos esta
situación que alemania pues ha tenido
ahí durante la segunda guerra mundial
una historia en ucrania y por el lado de
mandatario italiano y del rumano pues es
humano
esta visita porque también no olvidemos
que moldova y georgia también han
solicitado en este estatus de candidato
para poder ser miembros en unión europea
santiago para después de las atenciones
entre manuel macrón y volodymyr
zielinski con las declaraciones no del
mandatario francés quien dijo que
humillar a rusia no ayudaría a lograr la
paz usted cree que macrón ha
redireccionado quizá su discurso con
palabras más cuidadosas por decirlo de
alguna manera hacia kiev
sin duda alguna estamos viendo santiago
que este cambio de tesitura cada vez
cuida ahora más sus palabras o que
cuando digo este tema de la humillación
pues se encendieron las alarmas en todo
occidente porque pareciera que entonces
estaba a favor de la postura del kremlin
sin embargo sabemos que no es
precisamente la posición de francia
mucho menos un un país que finalmente es
líder y no solamente en la agenda
europea sino a nivel internacional
entonces pues estamos viendo que que van
a majo ya está haciendo más mesura